今天的策略用到两个TradingView指标
一个是唐齐安通道
另外一个是CCI
这里是澳元兑美元的15分钟图
当CCI从下网上穿过下轨
K线在唐齐安通道下轨与中轨之间时
做多
止损设在前一K线
低点之下
指引延
下轨移动
当K线穿过下轨时出场
这个例子盈亏比2.02.1
这里,CCI从下往上穿过下轨
K线在下轨与中轨之间做多
止损设在前一K线低点之下
止盈随
下轨而动
当K线穿破下轨时获利出场
这个是3.36比1盈亏比
这里是一个做空信号
止损设在前1K线高点之上
止盈随
堂其安通道
上轨而动
直到K线穿过通道上轨
只迎出场
迎亏比达到5.02比1
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
一共是47.55%
一般的杠杆是10倍
所以乘以10
就是475.5%的盈利率
做了49单
除以49
每一单
的利润9.7%
指标的设置点指标
输入
唐启安通道
点设置输入里面长度20变成21
样式里面
上轨把它变成白色
下轨也把它变成白色
点指标输入CCI
顺势指标
设置里面
输入长度20把它变成38
样式里面
CCI把它变成
绿色
上轨
不变
颜色把它变成白色
下轨一白也不变颜色
把它也是变成白色
点线形图
确认
操作方法
当CCI
从下网上穿过下轨
K线在
唐吉安通道下轨与中轨之间做多
止损设在前一K线低点之下
止盈随
唐气安通道下轨而动
当K线
穿破下轨时
止盈出场
当CCI从上往下穿过上轨
K线在唐齐安通道上轨与中轨之间
做空
止损设在前一K线高点之上
止盈随唐齐安通道上轨而动
当K线
穿破上轨时
只迎出场
CCI与上下轨不深通时
是非震荡行情不用操作
如果大家喜欢我的视频
欢迎点赞订阅
我们下一个视频再见
拜拜